ah that is creepy oh now don't do that
oh don't fall
that's horrible yeah hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome back to
five nights at Freddy's we're back at it
again it's your boy Marky Moo and then
we got foxy back there being a creepy do
you all God you do it to like the audio
is probably gonna sound a little [ __ ]
cuz I'm not in my normal recording room
but just remember I'm a little [ __ ]
so even steven now this isn't the fully
released version of his game yet the
game has some work to be done you chubby
little [ __ ] I'm gonna punch you in your
nose with the biggest of fists and the
lovely Scott Cawthon has allowed me to
play it a little bit early I don't know
why he thinks I'm special whoa oh I
wasn't even at the options did you move
who moved moved Apple shoes Oh subtitles
on Oh back if you're ready I'm ready
[Music]
let's do this
welcome to the Freddy fazbear's virtual
experience okay who's the console in
front of you to navigate the menu and
pick one of the frightening experiences
available by completing these scenarios
more will become available you'll see
plenty of familiar faces and some new
ones as well so stay a while and have a
good time no remember despite the
temporary horror you may experience this
is a completely controlled environment
and you aren't in any real danger
fazbear entertainment not responsible
for real danger please make a selection
from the virtual menu oh hang on a
second here hold on your your tuchus
there I have no idea if those subtitles
were even in frame if they look good I'm
kind of just praying that they look good
cuz if they don't look good then I don't
look good
and I always look good on me look at
these look at these bazongas look at
this gazonga BAM you see that [ __ ] let's
take stock of the situation here the
stage is there that's when [ __ ] oh 1 2 &
3 are gonna come rushing out at me and
tackle me in my gob we got a prize booth
over there which I don't remember seeing
real-time replay title news I mean out
of order why can't it work
I'm waggle in the waggle stick in it no
work my finger my finger can I go back
hand just for testing sake I'd hate to
get through all this oh wait what
wait whoa what did I do hey I've come to
the Freddy fazbear fruits wait Experion
rex fazbear entertainment is excited to
join the digital age and what better way
to do it than with an edge of your seat
virtual reality experience Wow
I don't know why I'm here I meant to go
back to the title because I wanted to
change some settings but um okay
we know that fazbear entertainment has
developed something of a bad reputation
over the last few decades while it's
true that some stories associated with
our name were loosely based on actual
events the majority of them are all
fabrications from the mind of a complete
lunatic lawsuits pending back laughing
at hours we created many of those
completely fictitious scenarios lies
that you've been fed
over the last several years into a
hilarious VR game in the hopes that we
can finally move past these childish
ghost stories and develop a new
relationship with you as well as your
kids don't forget the merch Bob for
birthdays just sit back and enjoy all
scarce oh oh
we do however ask that you agree to a
simple waiver before you play it's
mostly just a legal mumbo-jumbo and
isn't at all based on user experience as
thus far or injuries associated with
testing just touch the button to agree
oh and then we can jump right into some
harmless fun that can't harm you any
harmful way thank you for playing the
freddy fazbear's virtual experience
thank you I'm trying to read are they
close good if you agree to the term
frenzy you may press the button in front
of you or if you would like to further
reduce the consciousness transfer
weights real health manifestations of
digital character wait there's night
terrors what are you waiting on what you
say what are you what do you say about
night terrors and real-life
manifestations of fictitious characters
okay I meant to go all right it's fine I
guess
so I just have to Oh what the [ __ ] are
you what are you know you are you're a
bunny with purple eyes they are you the
purple bunny guy are you the purple
bunny are you the are you purple eye
bunny shirt stabber what are you gonna
do to me just tell me now I don't want
to wait for it all right so I don't know
what you are um I don't know what the
cassette was that I got let's go to the
prize counter boink
oh wow
that's cool what happened to bunny
but purple eye bunny some point
disappointment dated an unoriginal
boring mild passable lemon chica bar ooh
meat bites fast bar hey there's
something up there oh do I get ball
yes I've never wanted anything more of
my life oh [ __ ] my ball yeah hello I got
something I don't know what it was I
don't like you I'm gonna hold onto this
I still got bad for me um whoa whoa
that's that's so much game that's that's
too much game where's the search game
what are you even thinking grab what's
that one do wait there's a button over
here sorry I hit my tail was it yeah
it's give me the wink what does that do
hello I'm looking for six I'm on hunt
I'm like the game theorize ER call me
the game thunk er exactly thunk about
games real hard I'm gonna try to hike my
pants up ball night one let me keep my
ball [ __ ] fine max and Freddy's push
buttons pull trigger
alright wanna be same in the league Oh
hello oh can I actually hang out wait no
let me oh whoa whoa
[Music]
oh wait shut up I gotta go I gotta wait
hang on okay all right thanks you're
back bang why / chut up there we go okay
I know about the fight are everybody
hold on to your hats um cuz it's going
down I'm yelling timber oh oh oh oh
is he there if I lean out is he gonna be
there
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay all right that's
that's news to me
turn that I don't need to see oh [ __ ] Oh
Jay wait why I thought it did he did he
not he did not okay all right wait hang
on
yeah okay he went in the closet that's
good uh stay in the closet
me holy [ __ ] me oh [ __ ] me
okay well this is da new cut wait well
what are you still talking to me Scott
no oh God what's happening what's
happening what's happening Oh who's
doing it
stop no I know your dad I know you're
there
oh [ __ ] wait wait a minute
hi hi hi okay you're gone okay go go far
yeah yeah hey okay who's anywhere you
should be there
and yet you're not not there but you
should be there well you're not there so
where would oh [ __ ] [ __ ] no stop [ __ ]
no holy [ __ ] that's a big no [ __ ]
hell
[ __ ] stop wait okay just a sweet little
touch not a big treat sweet touch Oh
freaky [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you piece of [ __ ] okay are you there are
you going hello hi okay you're gone okay
I think do [ __ ] okay
just got a beat you I love tell thank
you all thank you okay kill me I mean
don't kill me
opposite of kill me oh you're all hi I'm
sorry I meant to make this camera a lot
more smooth than it was how do I
all right this is okay okay oh [ __ ] me
[ __ ] [ __ ] me you guys I can't explain
how actually honest-to-god terrifying
that [ __ ] okay okay it's 5:00 a.m. 5:00
[ __ ] yo I see you I see you oh [ __ ] I
see you oh my god I see you
holy show
oh [ __ ] I'm in the box
Oh God game one claim her prize oh wait
no don't you sack of [ __ ] are you
serious with this [ __ ] happening
with I know what you alright let's do it
oh that wasn't what I was expecting
Oh delicious so delicious okay okay
my poor hands and heart oh I don't have
a body I forgot okay all right wow that
was really freaking weird um okay I uh
oh hi again uh-huh yeah
really say what you meant to say carry
on kind of are you staring at my
beautiful face I know I'm really pretty
shall we try it again shall we
hi-yah we shall I die shall we shall and
we shall do and not because I'm brave
and so are you okay here we go
this is um this is happening all right
we in it to win it this time sorry I'll
I'll be a lot less [ __ ] this time I
swear on me yeah but you know what hello
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah no weird right oh god
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what
Boychuk it suck out what does the music
wow wait why okay you're there I know
you are I don't even need to look at you
I'm not gonna look at you I love you did
you go away okay you went away right
right oh yeah [ __ ] you were gone I don't
know guess it wasn't gone I guess you
know that's Sileo me not gone oh [ __ ]
you're not are you
there okay you're not there why are you
not go away okay you dude dude you're
not there so you're not there yet so
that's fine you're gonna be there and
you're you oh [ __ ] bye see ya hi hello
you then up there okay you're not there
wait you're not there okay you're not
okay okay okay wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait hello hi hello
okay no need for that huh you're still
there great that's good wait a minute
wait a minute hey ho let's go
you you just left it I know you you're
at the door you're probably at the door
a little closed drawer get on the door
everybody do it do the dance art okay
you still there you're not there
okay chicas good I'm good
we're all good you still there Hey okay
ho not there wait [ __ ] oh that's right
oh [ __ ] me Hey holy [ __ ]
crime Christmas Oh
dorsen early okay you're there are you
okay you're there
Jesus you're not oh I'm gonna die oh my
god for powers sake you're not there yet
oh but you're you're you're gone okay
you're gone
well you're there okay you're there now
and that's fine I'm not gonna make it oh
[ __ ] I'm not gonna make it oh [ __ ] oh no
wait Boop why there's no one okay no one
you still there go away - okay here we
go wink wink wink you there you still
there
you're there you're not there okay I
think the two prong approach is the best
oh [ __ ] you there oh yeah you're there
but you're not there yet but you're not
there yet
like the door no oh
brick time oh yeah you're there okay
you're there you're not there okay
don't do it to me don't who is doing it
and why put that out
I will [ __ ] you I will [ __ ] you up
Oh [ __ ] rice
okay right that was great um great game
11 out of 11 10 out of 10 yeah okay I'll
stall I'll do more of this definitely
real soon real soon so soon I'm gonna do
so much more so soon
just as soon as I clean the poop out of
my pants thank you everybody so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed this um yeah
I enjoyed it yeah that that's that
scariest game I played in a long time
okay so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought
down in the comments below I'll have
more five nights at Freddy's videos
linked in the description and I'll be
playing more of this just as soon as I
can find my balls again so thank you
again and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]